in 1998 Fox first aired the throwback
sitcom That 70s Show which became a
Smash Hit for the network followed up in
2023 by Netflix's that 90s show from
alternate titles to surprising casting
decisions here's the Untold Truth of
this classic Wisconsin set sitcom
perhaps one of the most well-known bits
of trivia About That 70s Show is the
fact that Mila Kunis lied about her age
in order to be cast as Jackie the show
had a policy that all actors had to be
at least 18 when they auditioned so
Kunis chose not to reveal her true age
as she was only 14 at the time during a
2012 appearance on The Tonight Show she
admitted I told them I was a little bit
older I told them I was gonna be 18
which is not technically a lie because
at one point I was gonna be 18. after
finding out that Kunis was underage The
Producers allowed her to stay on the
show as they felt she was a perfect fit
for Jackie the role jump started Kunis's
career and her co-stars helped her
achieve some important milestones in her
personal life Wilmer Valderrama taught
her how to drive Danny Masterson was her
prom date and Ashton Kutcher was her
first kiss and she and Kutcher
eventually even became husband and wife
in real life in 2015. before That 70s
Show Topher Grace had absolutely zero
professional acting experience he ended
up Landing the lead role of Eric Forman
pretty much by fluke on an episode of
people TV's couch surfing Grace revealed
that he was approached to audition after
appearing in a High School production of
a Funny Thing Happened on the Way to the
Forum as he remembers it I was in a high
school play and I was really only in
that because I sprained my ankle and I
couldn't be on the tennis team the
play's set designer turned out to be the
daughter of Bonnie and Terry Turner two
of the main producers of That 70s Show
after seeing Grace in the play the
Turners approached him shortly after he
enrolled at the University of Southern
California and asked him to audition to
play Eric Grace agreed and went on to
win the part
one of the most memorable supporting
characters on That 70s Show was Shirley
no-nonsense patriarch Red Foreman who
served as a constant foil to Eric and
his friends he was a well-written
character but what really brought him to
life was the performance from kurtwood
Smith haggling is part of being an adult
here's forty dollars
I want 50. knock it off
but as it turns out Smith wasn't the
actor that the producers originally had
in mind for red instead they really
wanted none other than Walker Texas
Ranger himself Chuck Norris by casting
someone as hyper masculine as Norris The
Producers hope to establish a clear
contrast between red and bookish nerd
Eric who had zero interest in
conventionally masculine activities
however Norris was unable to commit to
That 70s Show due to his pre-existing
commitment to Walker Texas Ranger and so
perhaps for the best the role ultimately
went to Smith
like some of his co-stars Ashton Kutcher
had precious little acting experience
prior to that 70s Show however he did
have a significant amount of experience
as a professional model his modeling
days began when he was a student at the
University of Iowa a Wandering talent
scout discovered him at a local bar in
Iowa City and encouraged him to enter
the fresh faces of Iowa modeling
competition he ended up placing first
and then he moved to New York City where
he signed as a model with the agency
next and appeared in ads for Calvin
Klein after a few years he decided to
shift towards acting and his first big
role was empty-headed teen heartthrob
Kelso while the role really launched
Kutcher's acting career he doesn't
exactly have fond memories of the first
season during Fox's 25th Anniversary
Special in 2012 he admitted that he
assumed his lack of experience would
almost certainly get him fired which
made him a nervous wreck in the show's
early days as he admitted I was so
nervous when I was hired for That 70s
Show I was doing everything I could to
look awesome I thought I was going to
get fired for the first three four
episodes I was convinced I was going to
get fired faking it until you make it
full blown for like the first entire
season
from the moment he first appears in
season two Leo proved to be one of the
most popular recurring characters on
That 70s Show played by Tommy Chong and
originally introduced as Hyde's
absent-minded hippie boss he was
promoted to main cast member status by
season 4 but then he was nowhere to be
seen during the 5th and sixth seasons
though his absence is addressed by Eric
and his friends in the season 5 episode
The Battle of Evermore apparently Leo
remembered he had a wife and child and
had to get back to them maybe
a UFO appeared
and it shot down a beam in reality Leo's
temporary departure was due to Tommy
Chong's arrest and legal battles in the
early 2000s he was reportedly caught up
in a 2003 police investigation trying to
Halt the sale of drug paraphernalia as
the financier behind his son's company
Chong was charged with Distributing
around 7 500 water pipes and bongs for
marijuana use he ultimately agreed to a
plea bargain that spared his wife and
son from prosecution as part of the plea
deal he was sentenced to serve nine
months in prison during which time he
shared a cell with Jordan Belfort of the
Wolf of Wall Street Fame after Chong
served his time he was welcomed back to
That 70s Show and so Leo re-emerged in
Point Place in season Seven's Down the
Road a Piece Chong became a full-time
cast member again for the eighth and
final season as Leo took a job at Hyde's
record store
any of That 70s Show fans who are old
enough to remember the actual 1970s have
surely spotted plenty of Pop Culture
references appropriate for the decade
case in point various episodes that take
their names from well-known rock songs
of the era specifically every episode in
season 5 is named after a Led Zeppelin
song and every episode in season six is
named after a song by The Who meanwhile
season 7 is dedicated to The Rolling
Stones and season 8 to Queen but that
rock and roll connection was originally
planned to go even deeper in the early
days of the show's production the
showrunners were going to call the
series Teenage Wasteland a reference to
the lyrics of The Who Song Baba O'Riley
could you please play
Baba O'Riley by the who's other
potential titles included the kids are
all right another song by The Who as
well as reeling in the years which was
tracked by Steely Dan the showrunners
also seriously considered using the
title of traffic's Feeling Alright as
the name of the show but Fox felt that
it wasn't strong enough as executive
producer Tom Warner revealed to The
Hollywood Reporter in 2012 fellow
producer Bonnie Turner said you know why
don't we just call it That 70s Show
because that's what everyone is going to
end up calling it anyway no matter what
we come up with they'll say did you see
that 70 show we all looked at her and
said you're right
few fictional sitcom cars are as iconic
as Eric's Oldsmobile Vista Cruiser the
station wagon that his Dad gives to him
that serves as the main means of
transportation for him and his friends
the cast members of course spent a ton
of time in it so inevitably certain
actors grew more than a little attached
in fact Wilmer Valderrama became so fond
of the car that he promptly purchased it
after the series wrapped in 2006. as
Valderrama revealed on the Kelly
Clarkson show in 2021 he went to the
props department and asked them to sell
the car to him the prop specialist soon
agreed allowing Valderrama to purchase
the car for 500 as the actor recalled
when I look at the car it reminds me of
when I was you know 17 18 years old
booking That 70s Show and doing that
opening sequence when we're just driving
in the street and honestly it's going to
be in my family forever and I truly
believe I'm going to put it in my will
and make sure that my kids have the
burden of keeping that car in the garage
you know honestly it's the best the best
thing I've ever acquired but my whole
career one of the biggest mysteries that
continues to surround That 70s Show is
fez's nation of origin throughout the
show he offers only vague hints about
where he's from and never outright
Reveals His official nationality not
only that but his actual name also
remained unknown when the series
concluded in 2006. this has never been
elaborated on by either the showrunners
or Wilmer Valderrama himself the closest
That 70s Show ever comes to revealing
fez's real name is the season 4 episode
class picture the friend group remembers
their first encounter with Fez when they
help him out of a storage closet after
he's locked inside by a group of bullies
when hide Kelso and Eric then introduce
themselves to him Fez recites a lengthy
name but the school bell rings at the
same time preventing viewers from
hearing the truth when Hyde appears
perplexed at the long name the gang
gives him the nickname Fez a casual
version of the acronym FES which stands
for foreign exchange student I know
let's call him Captain poo face while
fez's difficult name is played out up
for laughs there was a secret meaning
behind the scene when Valderrama is
drowned out by the ringing Bell he's
actually saying the first names of every
main cast member on the show the reveal
behind fez's name was meant as a subtle
inside joke that the showrunners thought
up for the series very special season 4
episode 20. we assume Tommy Chong was
very proud
when Topher Grace announced that he was
leaving That 70s Show at the end of the
seventh season producers wondered how
they were going to continue the show in
the wake of their lead actors departure
they ended up introducing a new
character near the end of season 7 in
the form of Charlie Schmidt in the
context of the series Charlie was the
son of one of Red's old war buddies
played by Brett Harrison he was
established as one of the new members of
the friend group with the eventual goal
of facing Eric out and replacing him
with Charlie however Harrison landed a
starring role on the fox show the loop
right around the same time so the
producers then decided to write Charlie
out of the show at the beginning of the
eighth season unceremoniously killing
him off after he falls off the water
tower as Harrison revealed to pop
entertainment.com in 2006 basically if
the loop wasn't going to get picked up
as a full series then I would have been
on That 70s Show for the whole year
because the loop got picked up they
threw me off the water tower
after Brett Harrison was no longer
available The Producers brought in Josh
Myers as a new addition to the main cast
to play the role of Randy Pearson in an
odd twist though Myers actually wasn't
hired to play Randy right off the bat
originally the showrunners hired him to
literally take over the role of Eric
Foreman in season 8 as discussed in the
DVD director's commentary of the Season
8 Episode Bohemian Rhapsody In This
original outline for season 8 Eric would
have returned from Africa as a changed
man to explain his physical
transformation into these significantly
taller longer-haired Myers but fearing
viewers potential reaction to Eric's
recasting the showrunners ultimately
chose not to go this route opting
instead to create a new character this
character who would eventually become
Randy combined some of the
characteristics of Eric and Kelso with
Myers acting as a successor to both
roles after Kutcher left the show near
the start of season 8 while also serving
as a prospective love interest for Donna
one of the first things that was said to
me about my characters he sort of is so
he enjoys people so much they're so
interesting
unfortunately fans reception to Randy
was mixed at best and Myers was
gradually given less prominent screen
time as the season progressed this would
continue until the very final episode of
the series with Randy only appearing in
one brief scene in the finale
That 70s Show featured a fair number of
famous guest stars throughout the show's
run one of the most recognizable was
Shirley Joseph Gordon-Levitt who played
Eric's Newfound best friend buddy in the
season 1 episode Eric's buddy in the
episode buddy and Eric quickly begin to
spend more and more time together
eclipsing the time Eric usually spends
with the rest of his friend group when
Eric confides his inner troubles to
Buddy one night buddy leans over and
kisses Eric revealing that he's been
romantically interested since the
beginning of their friendship you're
smart and insensitive and
nice looking
it's a moment that stands out since
there wasn't much romantic lgbtq
representation on TV at the time years
later in a Reddit AMA Gordon Levitt
shared the funny backstory behind the
famous on-screen Moment by revealing I
remember the director asking me and
Topher to kiss longer and then on the
next take kissing for what felt like
several minutes but when you watch it
our lips touched for probably less than
a second the actor also told Pride
Source in 2013 I certainly am proud to
have made that small contribution of
whatever kind to that progress
that 70s shows memorable opening
sequence features the main characters
singing along and dancing to Classic 70s
rock music while driving through Point
Place in the Vista Cruiser it's an intro
that perfectly captures an image of the
Carefree days of the era the theme song
entitled in the street was originally
written and performed by the band Big
Star and released on their cult classic
1972 album Number One record the first
season of the show features a modified
cover version of the song performed by
Todd Griffin lead singer of the 90s band
graveyard train with additional lyrics
contributed by composer Ben Vaughn from
the second season onwards the
showrunners opted for another version of
the song performed by Cheap Trick as is
standard practice for a song that
appears in a TV show or movie songwriter
and big star lead vocalist Alex Chilton
received a regular royalty check every
time in the street was used on the show
and the specific amount of money he
received was a hilariously coincidental
amount
seventy dollars as children quipped
Rolling Stone in 2000 it's actually
ironic that the amount is seventy
dollars to me it's that 70 show
one of the most innovative ways That 70s
Show got around establishing the
character's routine use of marijuana
without actually showing it was the
rotating camera from the series
signature Circle scenes amid a heavy
Haze of smoke the camera would
individually focus on one of the main
characters in a close-up then quickly
turn to another one and repeat this
process this was meant to suggest the
passing of a joint as everyone suddenly
becomes a lot kidier than usual
marijuana is the bee's knees
it was a clever way to appease the
sensors and soon became one of the most
memorable running gags on the show in a
2012 chat with smashing interviews
magazine Danny Masterson revealed that
the smoke was actually a combination of
scented artificial smoke from the props
department and smoked from his Ashton
Kutcher and Laura Prepon cigarettes held
off screen as he explained we'd be
smoking cigarettes and holding them low
and then they would just pump in this
movie smoke that smelled like
strawberries it was like some incense in
the background
at the peak of that 70 Show's popularity
Fox looked to further Cash In by
creating a Loosely connected spin-off
about the following decade fittingly
titled That 80s Show set in 1984 the
series focused on a group of friends in
their 20s living and working in San
Diego the focal point of the show was
Corey Howard played by Glenn Howerton
who would eventually go on to It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia Corrie is
an aspiring musician working at a local
record store who begins a romance with a
co-worker spiky-haired punk rocker June
I don't remember it ever taking this
long
debuting in January 2002 That 80s Show
garnered mostly negative reviews and
disappointing viewership numbers variety
for one declared That 80s Show attempts
to play off the decades superficialities
and the result is as conceptually thin
as a new waiver's tie owing to those
abysmally poor ratings the spin-off was
canceled after just one season on Fox
here's hoping Netflix's that 90s show
does better than its short-lived 80s
counterpart although it certainly can't
do much worse
That 80s Show wasn't the only attempt to
spin off the success of That 70s Show
there was in fact another previous
spin-off attempt in the form of days
like these a British remake that was
released around the same time is that 70
Show's first season like that 70 show
days like these takes place in the 1970s
and follows a group of teenage friends
but this time it took place in a
real-life town luden in Southeastern
England there are some slight
differences between the two shows with
certain characters names being changed
in the British version but days like
these retained many of the same story
lines as its predecessor as scripts were
recycled for the British counterpart
nowadays it's become rather commonplace
to see American TV series remaking in
earlier British show with the office
perhaps the most prominent example
decidedly less common is seeing a
British reboot of an American show with
something getting Lost in Translation
when the show crosses the Atlantic but
days like these is one such show as it
failed to gain any serious traction
among English audiences it was promptly
canceled with with just 10 of the 13
episodes that were produced ever being
aired on TV